wie viel man da verdient hat du hast mir
das gerade schon mal so ein bisschen
erzählt aber du kannst es ja noch mal
für die zuschauer erzählen also hättest
du jetzt im nachhinein also so gesagt
okay das hätte ich jetzt mal besser
nicht gemacht also hast du das dann
bereut oder eher nicht
ja man der fokus ist ja wieder mal on
point korrekt geht heute was geht ab
guten morgen ich bin gerade aufgestanden
ich treffe mich heute mit einer hilft
mir darstellerin und bei der cs hat sich
auch mitgemacht die hat mir nämlich
besser geschrieben nachdem ich dieses
interview mit jemandem gemacht habt ja
mcdonald's gearbeitet und das hat sich
für mich wirklich sehr interessant dann
gehört deswegen gehen wir jetzt erstmal
abholen ich würde sagen ich muss sich
beeilen muss bin ich zu spät wir sehen
uns gleich ich freue mich auf jeden fall
wird sicher interessant was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen
warte mal ich hab das video gerade im
auto schon angefangen also das ist die
tabea ich habe jetzt gerade abgeholt von
ihrem hotel herzlich willkommen ich
hoffe jetzt gut kurz vorgeschichte wir
haben vor drei oder vier wochen mal kurz
fenster geschrieben weil sie sich darauf
gewählt hat ich habe ja schon mal so ein
interview gemacht mit mcdonald's
mitarbeiterin darauf was zugeschrieben
ich habe bei hilfe mitgespielt und bei
deutschland sucht den superstar
ich habe mir deine hilfe folge zumindest
die ersten drei oder vier minuten habe
ich mir angeschaut und da auch ein
bisschen länger ich weiß ja nicht genau
gesagt auch nur irgendwie machen was
dann kräftig richtig aber wieder mehr
ist jetzt nicht gedacht 20 euro also und
fach so wirklich gut gemacht wirklich
gut gemacht und so muss das sein und du
meintest du bist wahrscheinlich eben
meinen köln weil du kommst aus
österreich und dass wir dann oder dass
du mir dann auch mal fragen beantworten
kannst die die zuschauer stellen und ich
hab euch gestern auf instagram nach ein
paar fragen gefragt für hilf mir und
auch für deutschland sucht den superstar
also wir machen praktisch ein oder zwei
videos müssen wir mal schauen fangen
aber mithilfe mir an weil da sind
wirklich viele fragen reingekommen ich
musste allerdings auch am anfang direkt
mal zu sagen ich weiß nicht ob du kennst
im sk nachdem auch ein freund von mir
der hat auch schon mal ein interview mit
einer hilfe mit darstellerin gemacht
oder die dort mitgewirkt hat deswegen
grüße gehen raus checkt das video mal ab
ist in der video beschreibung verlinkt
ich weiß nicht ob sich da eine frage
doppelt oder so
ich bin mir sicher wir werden auch noch
was neues erfahren deswegen lohnt sich
bestimmt auch dieses video zu schauen
oder ok gut dann würde ich sagen
starten wir direkt mann ich habe mir ein
paar fragen selber auch noch rausgesucht
und ich bin sehr gespannt vielleicht nur
so um reinzukommen
wie bist du darauf gekommen also jetzt
zu sagen okay dieses hilft mir das
spricht mich an oder wie auch immer
vielleicht ist ja auch irgendwie anders
reingerutscht
oder dass du gesagt hast ja okay ich
mache aber mit ich bin da bereits jetzt
bis zum 22
warte mal ich wollte sagen gibt es schon
drei jahre einfach nur ein taschengeld
auf besserung und ich muss auch sagen
ich kannte hilft mir wirklich nicht
wirklich also ich habe mir das nicht im
fernsehen angesehen und keine ahnung ich
habe da ich war bei seiner agentur also
die jetzt immer noch stage school was
gibt dir das sagen
sehr freuen bewerben und ich habe halt
dass man stellen anzeiger gesehen hab
gesehen okay da verdient man sohn zu
viel dann bewerbe ich mich einfach mal
und bin dann halt zum casting eingeladen
worden und paar wochen später bekam ich
einen anruf l wehrt eine rolle für dich
da geht es grob darum und das hat eine
hauptrolle und ich damals naiv an
einfach zugesagt ohne wirklich
nachzudenken und ohne diese serie
wirklich gekannt zu haben also weiß ihr
wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht auf
youtube gab konntest du auch wirklich
konntest du auch nicht nur wirklich
recherchieren was da so abgeht in der
serie oder danach schon recherchiert
aber wie gesagt ich hab ja gut also
hättest du jetzt im nachhinein also so
gesagt okay das hätte ich jetzt mal
besser nicht gemacht also hast du das
dann bereut oder er nicht bereut es ein
bisschen übertrieben aber ich finde es
muss nicht sein also es hätte nicht sein
müssen und ich würde es auf jeden fall
nicht noch mal ja gut dass das eine gute
aussage ich würde mal sagen bevor wir
jetzt weiter reden wir können ja mal
nicht um einen ganz kurzen ausschnitt
von der folge reihen und das in ordnung
ist und mit den 20 euro
ich warte krachen
weißt du was wir auch theoretisch waren
können wir können uns hinsetzen und uns
die ganz angucken aber ich weiß nicht
wie lang gegen die ok das ist mir zu
lang ach so genau das könnte jetzt die
hat auch ein youtube kanal verlinkt ihr
euch sehr gern mal in der beschreibung
dann könnt ihr euch das ganze mal
anschauen
nach dem video alles klar ja das hat
mich auch sehr interessiert wie man dann
dazu überhaupt kommt also ich bin schon
ich kann mich ja auch ein bisschen so in
der filmbranche aus und ich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass es halt so viele leute
die alle in diesem casting agenturen
drin sind und sonst was
und dann werden da ganz viel
angeschrieben und ein paar die einander
mitmachen finden sich immer dass wir
auch so eine frage von mir gewesen wie
man dafür gecastet wird weil ich habe
mich zum beispiel mal sehr gewundert da
hat so eine persönlichkeit mitgespielt
das waren
ein junger mann oder ich hätte ihnen
jetzt mal so auf 30 geschätzt und er
musste sein baby spielen hast du das
gesehen und das war auch so und das war
für mich so eine da dachte ich so alt
hat der arme wie ist er denn da
reingerutscht
ich bin euch auch super gerne mal ganz
kurzen ausschnitt ein
und da habe ich mich wirklich gefragt
also da habe ich mich gefragt wie der da
reingerutscht das weiße aber das kannst
du mir wahrscheinlich auch nicht gut
weil du grad schon gesagt das
taschengeld auf besserung
das ist so die frage die stellen immer
die meisten leute wenn ich mal sowas
aufrufe wie viel man da verdient hat du
hast mir das grab schon mal so ein
bisschen erzählt aber du kannst es ja
noch mal für die zuschauer erzählen wie
lange der dreh war und vor allem auch
was du dafür erhalten dass finanziellen
zusagen darf also ich hab keine
verschwiegen habt ihr in köln gedreht
oder in berlin
ich habe damals in der regel punkt und
das war's in berlin und es waren 450
euro ich möchte hier das ist natur indes
keine ahnung also pro tag 150
also das muss man wirklich sagen
pro tag 150 brutto also gut ist jetzt
bei die auch schon drei jahre her aber
ich sag mal so normale nebendarsteller
gage für so ein für so eine
filmproduktion das heißt wenn du da
einen tag mit spiels liegt eigentlich so
bei 3 bis 500 euro
deswegen also wahrscheinlich ist das
also hilfen wir sie eine low budget
produktion oder wie man auch immer sagt
deswegen ich kann gut ich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass es dann halt 150 euro
sind egal was das ist auch bei bauer
sucht frau oder ähnlichem wird
wahrscheinlich nicht höher sein als
diese 115 150 euro tagessatz auf keinen
fall also dass er gute alles klar
sehr interessant jetzt muss ich mal
schauen was dennoch befragen kann ich
sag mal alles gut klingt ruhig schmeckt
das wasser denn ok kölner wasser was ich
mich gefragt habe wusstest du bevor du
da hingefahren ist also du bist ja nach
berlin gefahren wusstest du im
ach so ok bresser bewohnt wusstest du im
voraus schon über deine rolle bescheid
also was du da genau spielen sollte das
heißt lag ihr das drehbuch vor also ein
anruf hat man nur eine ungefähre
informationen bekommen worum es geht in
der rolle
und dann haben die einen solchen zwei
wochen vorher vielleicht also man hatte
nicht viel zeit mit drehbuch geschickt
und das war doch nur so und es war ganz
komisch beschrieben so ich habe es
leider nicht mehr schade eigentlich
mitnehmen können aber so schlimm aber es
war kein normales drehbuch also ich weiß
wie normales drehbuch aussieht das alles
sehr genau beschrieben und das war halt
so der zwergenwiese ganz komisch
geschrieben also so dass man erstens man
konnte es nicht alles auswendig lernen
in der kurzen zeit also ich hab's
versucht das war echt schwer und die
beschreibungen waren immer nur so
ungefähr eigenen aber es gibt auf jeden
fall eintreten und du wurdest dann vor
ort auch nicht gezwungen irgendwas zu
sagen oder irgendwas in die kamera zu
sagen was vorher nicht im regen war oder
dass das produktionsteam gesagt hat habe
jetzt noch mal dass untertanen das nicht
aber es wurde eine schon gesagt zb wenn
ich musste öfters ausrasten in der sehr
gewendet irgendwie ausgerastet bin so
eskaliert
noch mehr schreien auch mehr um als die
der regisseur hatte schon okay also kann
man dann sagen dass du dem während des
drehs schon so gedacht hast okay darauf
habe ich mich jetzt hier eingelassen
ich hatte er einen lachanfall beim
drehen mehrere male aber ich hab mir
gedacht wo bin ich hier was ja eben
schon gesagt noch mal würdest du es
nicht machen dass wir dann in der
situation schon so dass es so hätte ich
das noch besser doch nicht gemacht weil
sich das für mich jetzt gerade anders
anfühlt als ich es geplant hatte so kann
man es vielleicht ein bisschen tue markt
also ich hätte dann nicht gedacht dass
ich dann so krass erleben oder sich habe
umgeschrieben ich hatte wirklich und
halsschmerzen vor interessant und das
produktionsteam was dann wirklich im
oder was dann vor ort war beim dreh
woraus bestand das wie viele leute waren
ist das interessiert mich also privat
sei als weil ich mich ja selber mit film
sehr auseinander setze ja gab es da dann
zwei leute oder waren das mehr mehrere
kameras ton aber wie auch immer es gab
hat einen kameramann dann gab es einen
regisseur wenn man ihn so nennen darf
hollywood und dann halt noch so zwei
frauen die ein irgendwie gestylt haben
also man hat halt der wirklich die
klamotten von ihnen bekommen ich wurde
auch geschwiegen weil es klar also schon
so fünf sechs leute die da mitgewirkt
haben in der zeit wo das dann im
fernsehen ausgestrahlt wurde oder
nachdem es im fernsehen ausgestrahlt
wurde kam ja dann soviel rezension von
deinen freunden oder auch von leuten die
durch dann auf der straße deswegen
erkannt haben oder wie war das so zu ich
weiß nicht oder jetzt vielleicht auch
nachdem das video auf youtube gedroppt
ist wobei man auch sagen musst du
hattest ja man erkennt ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt gar nicht mehr so
richtig wieder viele leute lustig
gemacht haben also in dem video eine
zahnlücke
da hatte ich noch die zahnlücke ja ich
hab die erst seit kurzem nicht mehr also
bei dsds haben sich die leute auch
darüber lustig gemacht inklusive wird
dieter bohlen ach so ja gut da kommen
wir dann später wenn ich auch mal
gespannt drauf die frage war ob du
dadurch auf der straße erkannt wurde es
sagen machen
meine freunde haben wir irgendwann alle
darauf angesprochen auch bekannte und so
auf der straße erkannt worden bin ich
eher selten also es kann schon mal vor
aber es war okay und von einer freundin
haben also positive rückmeldung oder
haben die einen oder anderen auch gesagt
wieso was das jetzt mitgemacht oder
keine ahnung ist ja auch eine erfahrung
weißt du also ich finde das auch so bei
mir auch immer früher viele gesagt
youtube-videos und so manchmal muss man
sachen auch einfach mal mitmachen und
sich trauen also das finde ich schon gut
in den mcdonald's interview hat zum
beispiel um die person gesagt mit der
ich das video gemacht haben oder das
interview geführt habe also ich kann
euch empfehlen bei mcdonald's zu
arbeiten du sagst hat sony leute lasst
uns mal die finger ich komplett egal was
andere von euch denken ist komplett egal
wenn ihr euch komplett zum affen macht
wenn ihr wenn ich das wirklich egal ist
dann bitte aber wenn ihr geld verdienen
also man muss ja wirklich mal so kurz
zusammenfassen wenn ich dazu die infos
von dir hast dort drei tage gespielt
hast ein tagessatz von 150 euro brutto
bekommen und wurde es dadurch noch in
einer sehr fragwürdigen rolle im
internet präsentiert oder im fernsehen
also ob es das wert ist ich glaube da
kann man schon auf andere wege geld
verdienen in dieser zeit ich muss nun
überlegen ob ich noch eine frage habe
oder ob noch eine frage von zuschauern
kam weil die meisten halt irgendwie das
gleiche gefragt vielleicht noch um das
ganze jetzt abzurunden eben welche
schauspielerischen voraussetzungen dafür
also wie ist das zu stande gekommen mit
der casting agentur ging es einfach nur
das optische obwohl vom optischen in die
rolle passt oder musstest du wo du
hattest du in dieser castingagentur
irgendwelche vorlagen du schon mal
der schauspielert hast oder irgendwie
sowas oder haben einfach gesagt okay die
sieht so aus als würden die rolle passen
die nehmen wir da jetzt also bei dieser
station agent oder hat die schönen
bewerbungsvideo drin vorstelle und fotos
von mir und dann wurde ich eben zu einem
weiteren casting angelacht da gab es ein
vorspiel und sonst noch irgendwas von
deiner seite was du zu einem thema sagen
würdest du so zum schluss irgendwie noch
ein erlebnis was du damit verbindest
oder oder sonstiges und ich sag mal so
die mädels mit denen das dann gespielt
hast kamen die auch alle aus berlin
ach so okay weil es gibt ja auch
sicherlich leute die extra dafür nach
berlin eingeladen werden um damit zum
spiel gegen die dann noch weniger geld
weil für die ja auch schon die
hotelkosten getragen werden oder geht
nicht dass die länder reisen dass die
reisekosten erstattet werden also kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen dass aussagen
ohne gewähr
aber ist schon echt hart also leute alle
meine zuschauer tut mir den gefallen
macht aber es war nicht mit auf keinen
fall das war es von dem kleinen hilft
mir interview ich hoffe es war angenehm
für dich und wie gesagt schaut gern mal
bei ihr vorbei da sind wir gerade gar
nicht darauf eingegangen
du hast mir ja gerade im auto erzählt
dass du jura studiert sogar weil das
fragen auch immer viele was man sodann
hauptberuflich macht oder so finde ich
so bin ich sehr sehr gut aber auch gerne
sehen
deswegen machen wir jetzt vielleicht
noch was zu deutschland sucht den
superstar teilgenommen
leider ok ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
lassen nach oben da jeden tag 19 uhr
gibt's neues video
und wie gesagt schaut gerne tabea vorbei
ist und der video beschreibung verlinkt
perfekt